anderson cooper is opening up about his
son wyatt's sweet bond with his newborn
baby brother sebastian yeah appearing on
live with kelly and ryan anderson
revealed his two-year-old son has
already become
came up with his own nickname for
sebastian and it sounds like little
white already has his first crush
take a look and we'll see you tomorrow
bye bye everyone
you gotta go back
so deeply in love with lola consuelos
that it's like a passion it's like the
love that burns of a thousand sons
i mean look at how he's staring at her
it is he even coordinated outfits with
her yes it is a mutual love he is just
so besotted like he could not take his
eyes off lola no i know it's like like
all boys
can he say he cannot say sebastian yeah
he can't say something yeah he calls him
luke and so every morning
he wants to go and say good morning luke
so that's him saying good morning to
luke and i like though he says the tweet
goes luke luke
like he's got a mild french accent yes
he does some mild french accent and when
he says my he says when he calls me
daddy he says it vaguely with a british
accent which is like daddy